hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
gonna answer a question from one of my
newsletter readers George he wrote in
saying he's 47 years old he's got his
MBA he started a company when he was 30
and for 17 years he's you know had the
best best time with his age is in his
best he's in his peak and because of the
crisis he's approaching bankruptcy he's
you know disappointed he's about to be
ruined and wanted some suggestions on
what to do next
so thank you for the question to George
that's a really tough situation to be in
something a lot of entrepreneurs are
facing I think for you the biggest thing
now is figuring out how can you go back
to making money you know any
entrepreneur can spend money and it can
be hard when times get tough and you're
used to a certain way of doing things to
keep up the expenses you got to figure
out a way to start making money and not
just spend money right anybody can spend
money it's that the challenge of making
money I mean you may have to pare down
maybe even all the way back to the
beginning you identify what it is that
you're really excited about passion
about try to identify customers who have
a pain point that you can go help them
solve and build around that I try to do
it around the service if you can
especially at the beginning biggest
couple of reasons one doesn't cost
anything besides your time so at the
beginning you know again we don't want
to be spending money here if we're
talking about bankruptcy you don't want
to be spending more money you want to be
making money so you're investing your
time you know you're trading your time
for money but you're making money coming
in and I want to see you get to the
survival point we're making enough money
from your service business that if you
want to expand enough for products then
you can't later on the first step is we
got to get you you know out of
bankruptcy and you know making money
enough so you can survive on a
day-to-day basis next thing I would try
to do is just keep in mind that you know
you 47 years old it's still young you
know it's not something that you're too
old to get started again even if it's a
completely different business it can be
really hard but you could chalk it up to
lessons learned and some experience that
you didn't have before but there's a lot
of entrepreneurs
had a lot of success you know still at a
much greater age whose partner Harland
Sanders from KFC was in his mid-60s
before he started KFC Ray Kroc from
McDonald's was again in his 60s or think
he was in his 50s I have a quote here
that I saved here for you that might be
inspiring so he said I was 52 years old
so Ray Kroc I had diabetes arthritis I'd
lost my gallbladder
most of my thyroid gland in earlier
campaigns but I was convinced the best
was ahead of me so here's a guy who you
know had a whole bunch of bad stuff
happened to him 52 years old at the time
where people are starting to think you
know getting close to retirement and
planning the rest of their life and
here's just starting up a new company
and built McDonald's into the success
that it was so there can be a lot of you
know still lessons to be learned and a
lot of excitement that could be ahead
for you I would start again around that
service identify a passion that you have
how you can help people provide a lot of
value the you know the amount of money
you're gonna make is gonna be depending
on how much value provides somebody and
how much you help them alright so start
a service around that slowly build it up
invest the profits back into the
business and then continue to expand and
hopefully you can get yourself out of
that situation and maybe with this
business or maybe doing something else a
lot of times people decide just to you
know shut the doors on that business and
start something new if you feel like
there's time to move on and sign them
law to a new project that maybe a little
bit more exciting and invigorating for
you so hopefully that helps I I'm still
you know positive for you and optimistic
for you I think with dedication hard
work and maybe pouring your heart into
it something you really enjoy I think
you can definitely turn it around and be
a successful entrepreneur and I'd love
to hear your progress and your plans for
what you're doing going forward so thank
you for the question if you guys liked
the video for those of you watching
please give it a thumbs up but makes
gonna do more of them for you and if you
have a question about finding your
passion or about you know being too old
to start a business or whatever it is
about your own company feel free to
leave in the comments below I always
read those and I always respond to
people as soon as I can so thank you and
I'll see you in the next episode